laurent baffie s'intéresse beaucoup aux
fils à papa il en est lui-même peut-être
points non on va voir l'homme un film
ghost writer
c'est un fils à papa avec toutes les
possibilités qu'il a pour réussir sa vie
toutes les ouvertures tous qui passe
bien l'intérêt qui passe bien il est
charmant louis des charmants mais il
manque de dimension un petit peu pas mal
quand même c'est pas mon genre
on me sens bien j'aime plutôt son père
vous pensez que son père était meilleur
journaliste ailleurs animateur mais un
animateur c'est vrai c'est un con comme
son père peut pas dire que ça je
trouvais qu'il n'a pas de talent drôle
quand même il écrit bien mais il a la
même gueule que son père ce pas de sa
faute c'est pas une critique ça peut
avoir la même gueule que son père est
talentueux oui mais c'est pas son cas
lui à wasquehal - ouais et en plus et en
plus si les frimeurs je n'aime pas en
fait il a le bon vivre c'est gentil hein
ça va aller à bientôt
le sport ils sont drôlement sévère ouais
ils sont du rhin oui je suis un peu
triste surtout son [ __ ]
oui oui n'ai plus rien à dire il parlait
ce qui est ton avis tous ces gens dans
la rue de mon père ouais mais il est
mort tu veux savoir de qui il parlait
oui tu va résister oui à la révélation
c'était pas de moi ben on regarde que
pensez-vous du fils tant pis si ça va
pas chez vous du fils de bernard tapie
c'est un con comme son père et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu